now the question is what
are the risks
voids boys what else
bad tense what else
[Music]
maybe it's a bad house maybe it's an
overpriced
house maybe it's rising down
what else come on hey fact could you
stand up
because this guy seems to know all the
potential problems so i want to just
list all of them
all right hello
there are a total of four
risks that could happen for problems
under categories and i want you to just
help me out coming
sounding boring through fireplace
chimneys
chimneys
so there are
no tenants
bad tenants which is worse than no
tenant
bad house
and then um act of god
like a plague
slash legals
could you help me out with these give me
some examples give me some examples of
my house
okay so the tenant's one can be sort of
it goes you've got tenants in but you
know they're leaving and there's like a
massive refurb needed
and then if you haven't seen the house
that refurb can kind of be
you can take the wallpaper off and then
half the wall can fall off
you've got rising damps i'd always have
a damn survey done and a normal house
survey
you've got potential issues with the
neighbours
uh potential issues with the tenants
having
up and coming problems uh obviously the
boiler the obvious ones
they're loft yeah which is a lot of
space
[Music]
are there any other categories that you
can think of
probably subsidence which would be one
that i've kind of acted
yeah would you agree there could be
millions of
subcategories within bad house yes but
ultimately bad houses and
anything damp related will get you or
someone only bought a church and it had
an underpinning needing doing this
all right cool the older the house the
more risks you're taking age-related
problems
yeah yeah yeah okay fine uh bad tenants
would you agree there's lots of
different targets in my towns yeah i
mean you've got some that you might have
to offer
like emotional assistance to you like
know about their jobs like charities of
civil servants and stuff
becoming money problems they can become
single through bad relationships
um someone i knew had someone drug
dealing from the house
so you can or yeah it can just be
someone just loses their job gets made
yeah so yeah sometimes it's attendance
sometimes it's not how many if you
actually look right now on a piece of
paper but what's your name again
uh andrew andrew if you don't want
another piece of paper every single
potential problem
that could ever happen within property
investing ballpark how many different
how many
types of problems you could write down
yeah millions how many 40 million
million
if you looked into if you looked into
the financial ones investment ones
you couldn't go wrong you've been gone
forever yeah it's going
your homework over the lunch is to see
how many you can
is it good is it really good yeah it is
it's really good
however what we're going to do now
because there is a time
for negativity sometimes there's a time
to be negative
so over lunch i've shown you how to find
a house
i've shown you how to work out the roi
over lunch i want you to think of all
the different risks and all the problems
okay
because what you'll find is every type
of risk and problem
all comes down to these four things but
the biggest
risk and problem which is a fifth one is
not a bad house but no house ah there's
a risk
it's okay to think of the reasons why
not but you need to think of the reasons
why two as well
so what we're going to do is after lunch
we're going to use this house
that we found for 50 grand and we're
going to do a risk assessment
you guys look at this so we're going to
look at okay
what would happen if there was no
talents and how long is that and how can
we prevent that
how do we prevent bad tenants how do we
prevent that being one of these million
things because you can't prevent this
would you agree yes or no so how do you
prevent this
act of god look if there's a plague in
half the planet's gone i'm
probably more concerned whether i'm on
the 50 that lived rather than my roi
but what i'm as if the house blows up in
flames what is it
if there's if there are things like this
yeah lightning hits and there are ways
to risk assess against this stuff which
after the last so what we're going to do
when we come back from lunch we're going
to go through all
the risks and how to prevent those risks
now if it was 100 risk-free
then it wouldn't be an investment it
would be called a guarantee so of course
there's some risk
the definition of an entrepreneur is
someone that takes a risk and hope to
make money
but what we want to do as smart
entrepreneurs if you want to de-risk it
as much as we can
so that it is it's as safe and as risk
proof as possible
now once we've risk-proofed it here's
what's going to happen we're going to
come back after lunch i'm going to take
your questions
we're going to risk-proof the property
once we've done that
if we can still have an 18 roi
20 ideally and risk through fair
then we're laughing then i'll take all
your questions
and then once you're comfortable and
confident i'm going to send you guys out
to find a property yourselves
do a risk assessment on it bring it back
to me there's gonna be people in the
room that find
deals that they go on to buy tomorrow
when i say buy tomorrow i mean like
secure or
tomorrow's no money down there there's
gonna be people in the room that find
houses today they go on to sell and make
money
there's gonna be some people in the room
today that by by the time you go to bed
tonight you're gonna be richer than you
are right now
and you can be someone that's i'm not
sure i'll wait and see and you'll see
that i was right but you weren't one of
the people
or you could say forget this i'm one of
the people man
if you're raising anything say hi all
right so we're gonna head down for lunch
uh before we head down for lunch uh
we're gonna let it go in a moment
i'm gonna get a couple of announcements
we're gonna let it go
we're gonna take an hour 20 minutes so
we're gonna come back at
um three o'clock what time please
all right also um if you wanna have a
chat
no i don't leave yet by the way
uh if you want to have a chat with my
team as well about questions
uh or if you want to chat about advanced
training speak to the guys they can talk
to you about that
but right now everyone please stand
up ready